[Applaudissements]
sur ce tour c'est un sport intense du
sport d'impact ou la tête en breton
des coups puissants et répétées qui mène
parfois à des commotions cérébrales
dans la ligue américaine de football la
nfl on parle de 250 commotion cérébrale
en moyenne par année
notre plan vise à stimuler la
transformation et l'amélioration de la
protection à la tête
[Musique]
fin 2019 la nfl donne le coup d'envoi
son grand concours le 1er mai challenge
le défi développer un casque de football
améliorée plus performant que tous ceux
actuellement sur le marché
pour nous ça représente quand même la
possibilité de gagner un million de
dollars à l'issue du concours
en juin 2020 parmi une centaine
d'inscriptions reçues la nfl retient
quatre finalistes dont le groupe
montréalais collègues
le groupe réunit les expertises de
coupole en impression 3d denimal jicks
en simulation numérique
de tactics en design
de chiffres que 3d en costaud mise à
sion et de l'école de technologie
supérieure
le ts pour les tests de matériaux et
d'impact
[Musique]
tous ont des expertises de niches
complémentaires mais aucune s'est
attaqué à la confection d'un casque de
foot bas encore moins dans un délai d'un
an
[Musique]
c'est très court pour développer un
casque ont plein le projet au départ est
il très à orienter un générique mais
dont le post romantique une boîte carrée
qui peuvent être fonctionner mais n'en
font qu'à elle peut plaire aux joueurs
donc c'est pour nous c est un aspect
important
se familiariser avec l'univers du vibal
ses codes et sa culture il recourt aux
avis des joueurs professionnels dont
martin bédard un ex joueur des alouettes
de montréal
c'est le casse mais évidemment le ballon
mais qu'on pense au froid je pense qu'on
pense à 1,15 ça correspond à nos images
référence autres comme tous les détails
sur le casque on trouvait en et forment
un petit peu plus carré
comme ni volume mais attendez que la
nation plus généreux mécène coquille ils
veulent surtout savoir ce qu'un joueur
cherche dans un cat
mais problème il faut qu'il soit
confortable deuxièmement il faut que ont
pu sabots une bonne vision selon les
positions qu'on a sur le terrain et puis
aussi la pesanteur du cast
et sur le poids la nfl est stricte on
peut aller jusqu'à 2.2 kg publication le
marché sont autour de ça jusqu'à 2.5 kg
en
limiter le poids et la taille du casse
tout en absorbant le maximum d'énergie
générées par l'impact où défilent
les ingénieurs se concentre sur les
accélérations linéaires de la tête mais
encore davantage sur les accélérations
rotationnelle plus susceptible de causer
des commotions cérébrales
pour arriver à absorber l'énergie le
groupe s'inspire de principes
d'architecturé entre iyh fabriqué en
impression 3d
donc ces structures se comprime à une
certaine énergie qu'il va avoir lieu
pendant l'impact et qu'on veut qu'elle
se déforme pour que ce soit les
structures qui absorbent l'énergie et
non pas que l'énergie soit transmise à
la tête mais tout reste à faire les
structures en treillis doivent être
optimisées pour un casque de foot pas
qu'on peut parler par exemple la taille
du mariage elle ça peut être aussi la
taille du filament avec lequel on va
construire notre mariage donc c'est de
trouver la bonne combinaison paramètres
qui vont nous permettre d'atteindre la
cible qui a été établi
pour accélérer le processus on teste
numériquement différents types de
maillage en fait que ce qu'on voit c'est
le mode de compression d'une structure
fait qu'on peut attester des géométries
vraiment différente puis comprendre
comment elles vont s'écraser pendant
l'impact on s'intéresse à deux
comportements en particulier le flamand
c'est la capacité de la structure à se
déformer d'un coup pour absorber
d'énergie et le cisaillement sa capacité
à résister à des forces latérales opposé
dans les laboratoires de le ts on est
ensuite physiquement le comportement de
chaque structure
[Musique]
comme le sport se pratique par temps
chaud et froid on doit s'assurer que les
structures d'absorption concerne leurs
propriétés mécaniques
peu importe le temps et le type d'impact
jusqu'à maintenant on a testé dont 48
différents prix alors qu'on pourrait
avoir par exemple différentes
caractéristiques de coussinets à
différents endroits du casque en
fonction de l'impact puis on va être
capable de moduler ses essais ses
coussinets en modifiant par exemple les
caractéristiques du crime
[Musique]
en parallèle et parce que le temps
presse martin laberge trace les
premières esquisses de la coque du
casque et de la façon dont les
structures d'absorption vont s'imbriquer
à l'intérieur donc ceci est une ébauche
ce qui permet d'avoir un peu aussi bon
c'est juste du dessin mais ça permet de
voir le foot le casque dans son ensemble
ou à la transparence
l'équipe doit se distinguer dans son
design mais sans déroger à la tradition
un casque de football doit ressembler un
casque de football du moins dans ses
lignes de base
entre autres c'est l'espèce de ligne
transversale qui va de l'avant vers
l'arrière du casque est à peu près
présente sur tous les casques la
configuration de la green et moi de la
tâche l'autre aspect qui est important
pour nous c'est les proportions du casse
pour y arriver on a littéralement
sculpter les formes imaginez en dessin
nous ce qu'on a fait ici ses économies
les proportions d'un casque du marchand
et puis deux côtés on ne crée une contre
forme d'argile qui nous permet de
sculpter de transposer ce qu'on
imaginait en 2d en décembre il transpose
entre rodez et non le tuer cette étape
là pour venir poser les lignes qu'on
imagine mais aussi bon retravaille les
proportions les petites subtilités des
surfaces
en parallèle les cellules où les
coussinets qui vont absorber l'impact
prennent forme avec les couches
successives de polyuréthane
thermoplastique
leur design est si complexe compte plus
les reproduire quand l'impression 3d en
fait c'est l'impression qui ne
respectent pas les plats traditionnels
donc on parle carrément d'un surface
qu'est horizontal et puis on migre vers
un plan qui est incliné donc comme ça on
respecte le contact avec la tête mais
aussi le contact avec le casque chaque
cellule à une forme et un tri
particulier en fonction de la zone khz
et le culte dans le casque
95 cellules seront réunis dans le
prototype tout retenu ensemble par un
harnais qui lui se fixe à la paroi
intérieure de la coque ce c'est la
première version de notre oeuvre kas
complet avec le manioc je pense qu'ils y
votre art et essai c'est mou mais pas
trop me j'aime le fait qu'il soit à côté
bien comme il faut partout autour ne
venez pas d'un ehpad espace où ils pas
de contact sur la tête au premier abord
tout les côtés
pendant que les désignent travaille à
l'amélioration du look et du confort du
casque les ingénieurs même des tests des
pack numérique sur le modèle en
développement
les designers industriels sont des gens
très créatifs qui est pitch beaucoup
d'idées nous notre travail c'est de
venir tester ces idées là de façon
virtuelle pour pouvoir prendre les
décisions très rapide
des éléments qui a soulevé des
discussions entre ingénieurs et des à nu
c'est une légère great stylistiques ou
le bridge comme il l'appelle à l'arrière
du casque elle pourrait être en plein
sur la cible d'un point d'impact du test
de les avoir une grosse concentration de
contraintes au niveau du ridge puisse
aussi en mode 2d failli ce qu'on veut
pas qu'on le dit un petit voter modifier
un peu notre approche pour cette vous ne
pourra enlever ce détail le modifier
pour être capable de limiter les risques
de moins bien performé hôtesse à cause
de ce détaillant
[Musique]
pendant ce temps là qu'ils font
assembler en toute vitesse un banc
d'essai pour procéder aux tests d'impact
sur des produits finis
c'est un test où on voit un pacte et
dont un casque sur une tête à
instrumenter il ya six directions d'un
pacte à trois vitesses différentes donc
18 caisses pour un test pour établir le
score d'un casque on va faire dix huit
impacts puis à partir de ce 18 un pas
que l'on va recueillir l'accélération
linéaire mais l'accélération aussi
rotationnelle pour chacune des
situations
les points d'impact sont basées sur une
analyse fine de la nfl a réalisé à
partir de vidéos de jeux qui ont mené à
des commotions cérébrales
le texte impose un coup oblique à
l'arrière du casque un autre à l'avant
deux coups sur les côtés dont un plus
haut que l'autre et deux autres impacts
sur la grille
la femme était csu à 5.5 personnes
dis moi un après le début de la
compétition
la longue série de tests d'impacts
commence des tests identiques à ceux qu
la nfl fera subir à tous les quatre ans
plus les structures à l'intérieur du
casque le groupe montréalais miser sur
une coque molle pour absorber encore
plus d'énergie lors de l'impact
[Musique]
la nfl exige que les casques déposé au
concours réduisent au maximum les
accélérations de la tête
l'objectif est fixé à 3 70
[Musique]
la nfl estime que c'est une performance
d'environ 15% supérieure à celle des
meilleurs casques sur le marché
une cible difficile à à terme donc
jusqu'à maintenant on ne peut plus
atteindre points 78 ce qui est un bon
score si on compare par rapport à ce qui
existe sur le marché atteindre une
pareille performance en si peu de temps
pour une équipe qui partait de zéro ou
presque c'est un exploit ouvert
en juillet 2021 donc un an seulement
après le début officiel de la
compétition leur prototype pas se
mesurer aux concurrents on est très
fiers de ce qu'est ce que la après avec
mes yeux de chercheurs je veux encore
toutes les choses qui a amélioré pour
l'année encore plus loin l'annoncé du
gagnant par la nfl doit se faire donner
ce temps à l'autre dans sa taille gagne
on s'attend à clé parmi les meilleures
équipes pré certainement puis on ne
s'attend surtout à ce que le cas suscite
tellement d'intérêt qu'on ait des
propositions pour en poursuivre le
développement pour éventuellement aller
à une commercialisation qui sait le
super bon mettra peut-être jour en
compétition de génie le design d'ici
dans un thé match enlevant où le casque
ton en champion
[Musique]